and there's layers there too
i remember training with you it's it's
kind of funny there's like
there's well you didn't know who i was
i mean you still like i have a really
good straight neck a lot by the way yeah
that so i i don't remember what rank i
was
but it might have been purple or
something like that and
i did some like i you had this look on
your face which i've often seen in black
belts
it's like here he goes again like
here here's him trying this thing and
then
when i kind of annoyed you a little bit
with it now i get that
it was a good like i you know i did
something somewhat effective like some
like maybe a little bit off balance yeah
there's
i just peeled off a little layer of ryan
hall to where i was like okay let me
let me like there's there's like layers
to the underneath these
somewhere in there like so it was like
okay this like
new guy rolls in here he thinks he can
do the stupid thing
and then and then you started to beat
the hell out of me but the the point is
there's layers
here from the guy who was being
interviewed now to
like genghis khan but it's but it's all
in the same body
right but it's like all of us are like
that right in various different
directions and recognizing that's okay
it's just
there are consequences to all every
choice that we make as a consequence
sometimes there's like objectively wrong
or objectively right but at least in my
mind that's a pretty small box
everything else is just there's a
consequence of that do you like that
consequence do you not
and who do i want to become what do i
want to try to
hone myself or anyone else into and also
like
but this is something i've screwed up as
a coach plenty of times you know like if
someone says if you're if like i come to
like lex
i really really want to take you know
research very seriously like okay i
believe you
now i haven't shown you that but i
believe you're like okay
and now me not showing up to research or
to study or not being up until three in
the morning thinking about this is no
longer acceptable
there was a time like five seconds
before me making that statement that if
i went to bed without reading the book
that i needed to read
no worries but the second that i made
that statement your your expectations
for me changed and maybe it's something
that's something that i've screwed up a
whole bunch of times in my
um as a teacher because it's an
interesting thing obviously you know
being a like running a martial arts
school is as you're principally an
athlete
is sometimes i don't pay enough
attention to what people are doing i
just go oh okay you say xyz i'm like
roger that i believe you're cool
i will now put you in category x and
whether rightly or wrongly like maybe
this person didn't understand what they
were asking for or i didn't express
this or the other and it just it caused
cross wires and then most times
you hash it out you have a discussion
you figure out you get to the bottom of
what people are trying to do or what
they want
but uh if i was paying more attention i
think i could have been a lot more
effective or if i had more experience
and sometimes maybe i'm not sharp enough
or i don't person i'm not perceptive
enough to be able to
to see what's going on and maybe with
years more down the line i'll be able to
have a sharper perception but uh i think
that's another one of those interesting
things that
some that sometimes i would caution or
not caution but just a
a perspective martial arts student
depending upon where you're going
um you know this you you both you and
also your coach or other people in the
room they wear many hats and sometimes
there's a i had the wrong hat on you
were talking to me
as lex the guy i didn't realize you were
talking to me i thought you were talking
about lex the guy i didn't realize she
taught me his lex the martial artist i'm
like oh crap
i was talking to the wrong person so
it's almost like if you had a like i run
my gym with my wife she's a black belt
so
she's my wife she's my peers as a
martial artist
uh on in jiu jitsu he's here by the way
in judging so exactly
all right well all right so but a fellow
black belt and i guess like another he
doesn't have a microphone so you can't
hear all the trash he's talking exactly
but it can be tough and that's something
we've had to work through a lot and it's
like looking back and it's like now
being where i'm at now and it's easy to
say that because she's in the room and i
don't want to stab me just continue to
slowly poison me over time
yeah which frankly i understand um you
know it's
it's the sort of thing that is now way
more effective than anything else i
could really reasonably expect to have
um but there were times when when both
of us you know were justifiably annoyed
at the other because of crossed wires
and sometimes you know you just have to
scream in anywhere misunderstanding
anyway but
again like i've i coach some of my
friends i've coached i've coached my
friend who i've known since i was four
years old
you know sometimes i don't go hey buddy
how are you doing something's like what
the are you doing put your hand
over there how many times we talked
about this and then you walk away
and you can see him look at you crooked
and you're like oh crap oh yeah he
thought i was talking to his friend
yeah well all right we need to talk this
one out hashing out and not
he's wrong how could he possibly think
that way like oh no i totally understand
that
but if i was 22 like doesn't he know i'm
a purple belt
some nonsense like that and it's and it
doesn't come from a bad place but it's
just i guess that comes back to society
to anything people only have the
perspective that they have and the
awareness that we have
and so again going back and going hey
guys grace like i don't expect it's not
fair for me to go i put
ufc why doesn't this guy who came in as
an attorney understand how hardcore this
needs to be and like how could he
yeah and at the same time though if if
i'm using the language of
someone that is interested in at least
performance from a martial arts
perspective
i understand how that could be
off-putting let's say for instance
someone that's
like all of that would be out of bounds
in their normal workplace but if they
think of the gym as my office
then whether they agree or disagree with
what's going on they go okay i hear why
i see why that might have happened let's
talk about this
and we can again all push forward in a
positive direction
that benefits i guess everyone's journey
throughout the activity
you